here with me now is the former
conservative party co-chairman and
supporter of rishi sunic oliver dowden
uh oliver good morning to you thank you
good morning let's pick up on what we've
heard from the prime minister right now
a good idea to hold daily emergency
cobra meetings well of course we need to
be on top of this situation and we need
to be
realistic and honest with people about
the scale of the challenge that we're
facing both with the scale of inflation
that's coming down the line something we
haven't seen for almost 40 years and
with the fact that energy bills are
going to go up possibly towards 4 000
pounds i would say though i don't take
enormous lessons from gordon brown
remember this was the man who gave the
75 p
rise for pensioners so he's not really
got a great record on this sort of thing
oh he's also the man who guided the
country through the financial crisis in
2008.
well we we we could trade stuff about
gordon brown he's he's also the person
that left us with no money left and uh
sold the gold at the lowest price
possible so um i think conservatives are
perfectly capable of dealing with this
situation ourselves and you've seen that
rishi sunak did that when he was
chancellor he announced an enormous
amount of support for people uh in
expectation of this rise in energy bills
up to 1 200 pounds for those on the
lowest incomes it's that kind of scale
of direct intervention that is required
and i think uh
just uh proposing to cut the national
insurance contribution which will only
help people on the lowest incomes
working full-time the national living
wage by less than 60 pounds it is not
sufficient to this scale of challenge
that's a list trust side it's not gordon
brown's we'll come on to some of that in
a moment do you think there should be an
emergency budgets then whoever is next
prime minister to deal with the crisis
we're facing uh well i think we need to
take bold and direct action in response
to this and i think you've seen from
rishi sunak when he was chancellor both
in response to the furlough scheme
when he came up with that in a matter of
days that saved millions of jobs and the
action he and prime minister boris
johnson took earlier this year it's that
kind of scale of intervention that is
required not an emergency budget bold
and direct action is one thing an
emergency budget is what's needed isn't
it well these things don't necessarily
have to be done through an emergency
budget so if you look at the
200 pounds that was
announced earlier this year that wasn't
through an emergency budget but i think
there is no doubt that we do need
an intervention of a considerable scale
to deal with this because we have to be
honest with people about the scale of
the challenge that they're facing so
that's an acceptance then that the
amount that was promised earlier in the
year is inadequate and more money will
be needed for those most in need yes i
think that's that's almost certainly the
case we'll have to see exactly what the
the bills end up uh being we know
they're going to be three and a half
thousand well let's see when we know the
exact level of the price cap but if if
it looks like it's going to be at that
kind of scale then of course we'll need
further
intervention so we have already seen uh
an announcement from rishi soon that
that he would remove vat on fuel bills
temporarily to help through this crisis
but i'm sure that further action will
also be required what about an increase
in universal credit to help those most
in need who will be suffering
well actually if you you look at
universe credit that is something that
uh richard zunat was willing to do both
during the the kobet crisis when he
increased it by 20 pounds and indeed uh
when he eased the taper rate to help
people
uh to to keep more of what they earn on
those lower incomes but i think that
then you took it away so i mean we're
going into another huge crisis now in
the winter will that happen again do you
think
well we've been clear that support will
be temporary and targeted so the vat cup
will be temporary when bills fall again
then that support won't be required but
i think that the point about all of this
is and i think there is a genuine a
difference of opinion between uh
liz trust and reggie sunak on this that
the rich snack accepts the need for this
these bold big interventions uh
liz trust has put her emphasis on this
tax cut and it's important for your
viewers to understand what that tax cut
means for the prime minister whoever the
prime minister is that'll be worth 1 800
pounds a year a considerable sum up to
the the scale of the increase in bills
for somebody working full time on the
national living wage it's worth less
than 60 pounds so we need more and
bigger direct intervention support
people and that's why i was somewhat
concerned by the the position announced
uh on saturday in the financial times by
by liz trust again it's not entirely
clear what what the position is now on
that i mean you're not clear i don't
know if we're clear we're gonna speak to
brandon lewis uh later in the program to
find out exactly where it is so you
think just liz trust just doesn't get
the scale of the challenge we're facing
i think liz trusts a very um capable
person i've had the pleasure of working
with her for a number of years this is
not about a personal thing this is about
judgement though as a leader of the
conservative party and prime minister
and i think what you've seen with rishi
sunak is the judgment that he showed
when he dealt with the cobart crisis
it's that kind of big intervention that
is required and my concern is that if we
simply rely on a reduction in the
national insurance contribution rise
then that is not going to help the
neediest people but it will help
people on higher incomes it won't for
example help pensioners no it won't
let's just talk a little bit about what
you see like of course you would have
seen uh for the past few days this video
doing the rounds on social media
appreciate soon as speaking in tunbridge
wells talking about making sure that
money would be going to
areas like that taken away from deprived
communities making sure it was spread
out i mean that has left i think a bit
of a sour taste in his mouth let's in
focus now let's have a listen to that i
managed to start changing the funding
formulas to make sure that areas like
this
are getting the funding that they
deserve because we inherited a bunch of
formulas from the labour party that
shoved all the funding into deprived
urban areas uh then they you know that
needed to be undone i started the work
of undoing now
i mean he said he's gonna undo that i
mean that might play well in tumbridge
wells probably doesn't play well in
places like darlington where he's going
to be later in the week and it certainly
wouldn't play well if he came up against
labour in a general election would it
well i think the the point that rishi
was making with which i agree completely
is that we need to focus resources on
when they're where they're most needed
and it's quite easy so if you just let
me finish this point it's quite easy to
dismiss the south east of england say
there's not a deprivation there if you
take my own constituency of heart smear
it has some of the most affluent places
in the country in it but right next door
in the same
constituency one of the wards is in the
the 10 of most deprived boards in the
country now it's right that places like
that should get support as part of
leveling up and that's precisely what
rishi sunak has been saying i think what
you saw under the labour party was large
amounts of of resource going into
in the cities and ignoring those areas
of deprivation that exist across the
whole country and i think it's it's
perfectly right that rishi soon that
changed the formula in that way somebody
should be going to leafy places like
tunbridge wells as opposed to places
that are perhaps more urban it needs to
be in the the most needing places and
that doesn't just have to be in urban
inner city areas and i see that in my
own constituency why do we think that
richie sunic is behind in many of the
polls that we're seeing right now that
mr darden
well i i've been in politics
well i'm not saying you can't trust the
polls what i am saying is we have seen
time and time again that polls have not
proved to be correct whether that's in
relation to brexit donald trump you you
name it all different polls come out the
key thing is the members i trust the
members of this this party i work with
incredibly closely as chairman and over
many years i know that in the end
they'll look at the candidates and they
can seem risky sooner someone with the
values with the experience and the
capability to lead our nation